i i want to focus in on the election
piece just so we
we kind of keep to keep that path
forward there are some
like marjorie taylor green who while she
believes there were problems with the
election
she says trump is not coming back he it
is false hope to believe he will be
reinstated you've said august or
september
do you still believe that and what's the
mechanism
a hundred percent i believe that she's
she's misconstrued i mean they all these
this is uh here's there's a couple of
things here um
we're having the cyber symposium after
that that's august 10th 11th and 12th
everybody's going to watch this it's i
want it to be the biggest watched event
in history yep billion people
you watch that and you're going to see
the packet captures and data from the
whole election
this is non-subjective evidence
everybody it's what i've had for months
now
and i've been trying to get the word out
but i keep let's just cancel mike
lindell in my pillow
i've been trying to get the word out now
this gets out
we've had it ready for the supreme court
it's called a quo warranto
we bring that to the supreme court and
everyone says well they're not going to
bring back donald trump yes they are
here's why
so hold on mike i want to i want to hear
it but i want to make sure the audience
doesn't miss it
the supreme court is the mechanism that
will bring them back you're saying
there's there's more than one but i'm
giving you the first one okay okay
the easiest one okay okay the easiest
one
this when we get through the cyber
symposium which everybody needs to tell
everybody to watch this
is so important because these nine
supreme court justices
they're people too they've lived the
american dream they have families they
have children grandchildren
friends family they need to everyone
everyone needs to watch this because it
shows
that this was an attack by china on our
country
it doesn't matter if you're a democrat
or republican i said on jimmy kimmel i
said
jimmy said if it was reverse mike would
you do the same thing
absolutely i would this is an attacker
in our country
so what happens is in our country's
history
every elected official everyone
that you find out later there was a
crime committed i.e election fraud
the real winner gets put back in it's
happened
every single election now that's never
happened at the presidential level
right that's the only difference so
there is precedence
but also you you combine this with this
is attacked by china
this was a very very very uh it's a it's
an act of war
basically as wow they've attacked us and
the democrats warned us of this
everybody they warned us from my senator
amy klobuchar to kamala harris
they all warned us about this cyber
attack about going through the machines
and taking our country without guns
and uh they just happened to use the
democrat party so no matter who you are
we go back together now the warrant the
the supreme court is going to get this
yeah we're going gonna give a probably
late august and now what they do with it
i'm not the supreme court
but they'll have some options they might
put you know pull it down and put donald
trump in right away because his evidence
is non-subjective
i see or or because all the down tickets
were affected too
many many down tickets maybe the supreme
court i'm just putting out there has a
whole new election
wow well how could we have a new
election
right with these with these machines we
can't
but at the symposium on the 10th 11th
and 12th of august
remember live streamed on frank's speech
worldwide of course
and worldwide frank speech.com we're
going to live stream at 72 hours
straight
we're going to unveil replacement for
the machines
and everyone says well mike are you
going to do that now you're going to
show this
is just a money thing so you can make
money no we're giving the technology
away to all companies
okay okay but so to one i want to go one
thing because there's so much here my
head is virtu
it's literally spinning here mike um
just to show how
confident you are that this
reinstatement would happen
would you want to make a financial bet
with me on it because i just don't see
it and i want to prove to people just
how confident you are
would you want to put 25 000 up against
me on it that by the end of september
trump is reinstated one of my addictions
was gambling
ah but not but i will tell you this i
put up
5 million dollars a
prize yeah cyber symposium five million
dollars
for anyone that's there which is we've
invited now we have over a hundred cyber
cyber forensic experts from around the
country and a couple from
out of the out of this country